can you put a price on DLC well quite
frequently yes yes you can but not this
time
Ubisoft is giving away free DLC for the
division inspired by the games just
announced live-action digital series
this offer only seems to work if you're
in America but if you are let's carry on
I'm Lucy and welcome to this free
region-locked
GameSpot news update so the digital
series agent origins follows the stories
of four division agents and likewise the
free dlc is themed around four
characters paramedic firefighter police
and hunter as explained on us website
the DLC consists of gear sets to give
your character a swanky new look and
some extra skills if you are in the
United States of America to claim your
free content head to the website listed
below choose your platform and redeem
the code agent origins all caps in their
space you'll then receive an email that
explains how to redeem the gear but do
note that you can't redeem the content
until the division launches in March the
divisions closed beta begins on January
28 to Xbox one owners who pre-ordered
the game while ps4 and PC users can get
started on January the 29th the Vita
ends on all platforms on January 31st so
you're looking forward to gearing up in
post pandemic New York's let me know in
the comments below or come find me on
Twitter I'm at Lisa James games for
latest on the division make sure to keep
it GameSpot
[Music]
you